we're gonna spend a couple of minutes
talking about the binomial theorem which
is probably familiar to you from high
school and is a nice illustration first
illustration of the connection between
algebra and computation so the idea that
underlies the connection is illustrated
by the distributive law and I'm
purposely writing it in this wacky way
of it's purely symbolic where I'm gonna
multiply three beanies by two both
neckties what do I get if I multiply
three beanies by two neckties well
appala applying the distributive law
says that we get every possible pairing
of of a beanie and a necktie multiplied
together and you add them all up so
there are three terms here and two terms
there I'm gonna wind up with six terms
which you see laid out the basic rule is
that a product of sums by the
distributive law becomes a sum of
products and the sums that you get
involves products of all of the terms
from each of the components in every
possible way
let's look at that as it applies to the
binomial theorem so the binomial theorem
is interested in the question of let's
look at the expression 1 plus X raised
to the nth power and we know that this
will be a polynomial of degree n so it
can be written in the form a constant C
0 plus C 1 times X to the 1 C 2 X to the
2 C NX to the N and we'd like to ask
what are the expressions for C K so for
example here's a layout in the first
four powers of X let's say 1 plus X to
the fourth is 1 plus 4x plus 6 x squared
4x cubed 1 X 4 what's the pattern that
underlies those coefficients 1 4 6 4 1
well one way to think about it is that
if I wrote out 1 plus X to the N fully
it is of course a product of n
occurrences of 1 plus X times 1 plus
and applying the distributive law the
product of sums equals sum of products
rule but this time there are n products
and what I wind up with is 2 to the N
terms that I'm adding up each of them is
a product of a selection of n items one
from each of the factors so a term among
these two to the N terms corresponds to
selecting a 1 or an X from each of the N
factor so if I started off for example
by selecting a 1 a 1 a 1 from each of
the in fact as I get the term 1 to the N
if I selected an X and X and X and X
from each of the terms I get this last
term X to the N and if I made some
arbitrary selection like I selected an X
from the first one and a 1 from the
second one no one from the second one
from the third one I'm reading this term
one from the fourth and so on and a 1
from the next and X from the next to the
last and a 1 from the last I would get
this particular term which is not the
next one that would occur in
alphabetical order but it's just an
example so that's the simple idea if you
multiply out n terms each of which is a
sum of two things you're going to wind
up with 2 to the n terms corresponding
to every possible way of selecting one
or the other of the terms of the
components from each of the N products
so what's the coefficient of x to the K
well the coefficient of x to the K is
the number of those terms among the 2 to
the N in which the power of X is K that
is in which I selected K X's and
willy-nilly n minus K ones well how many
ways are there to select K X's among
these n terms and we know the answer to
that it's n choose K it's all the ways
of choosing a subset of K items out of n
items and that's the answer
CK is simply n choose K and this is
called the binomial formula so now we
know that 1 plus X to the N is n choose
0 plus n choose 1 X and
choose two x-squared and choose K X to
the K is the general term ending with n
choose n to the X to the N so this
expression 1 plus X is called a binomial
expression and the the choose numbers
which we've seen previously as the
number of ways to choose say in this
case k out of n elements are called
binomial coefficients and this is why
they're called binomial coefficients so
if I was going to express it more
generally I didn't need it to be one I
used 1 plus X just because it was easier
to follow the structure of the formula
but if I look at X plus y to the nth
power again the coefficients are the
same it's n choose 0 but this time Y to
the N and choose one X Y to the N minus
1 what's happening now is that I'm
choosing an X or a Y instead of an X or
a 1 from each of the terms so that the
the X Y terms are always going to have a
sum of degrees that's equal to n if I
choose K X's I must have choose and
chosen n minus K wise and there it is
expressed in a more concise form using
Sigma notation that is the binomial
formula